So starting from left to right, starting with
you. Guy, could you please say hello and
introduce yourself and share a little bit more
if you wish?
Yeah. Hey, everyone. I'm Guy. I'm a solution
architect at Komodor. I'm here for the last
two years. Very excited to
join Cluster.
Cool.
Hey, everyone. My name is. I'm a software
engineer.
I came week after guy,
and this is it.
And hey, everyone. My name is. I'm the
CTO of Komodor. We like watching Clustered. Happy
to be here.
Alright. Thank you all very much. So this
is a special edition of Clustered, and I
have broken the cluster personally myself with a
handful of bricks to hopefully reveal and show
us the power of Komodor as a tool
for understanding and debugging problems within your cluster.
So with that being said, I will now
let Guy share his screen, and we will
begin the debugging process. Best of luck, team
Komodor.
Thank you. Let's let's start. Cool. There you
go. So we got our cluster
with
Komodor installed.
So
I will consider this cluster fixed
if
we can port forward and visit the Drupal
website.
That is your mission.
Okay. Sounds easy. Right? Sounds Easy. Right? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
The reason is it's for scheduling.
Yeah. So we can go into, like, the
service in Komodor and see the timeline. Alright?
Like, how did the service change over time?
And you can see that it's currently broken,
and you can try and understand why is
it broken. So why is
it broken? I I see there is a
heavy deploy,
like, in 01/1525.
Oh. If you open timeline. So do you
mean, like, oh, to zoom in? Yeah. Okay.
There you go. I think it's, like,
great story of what happened.
Yeah. And you can see there is a
change in GitHub.
Yeah. There was a, like, an awesome update.
Like, they they update. Was it an awesome
update? We will Okay. No. Gotcha.
And he, David, removed
some environment variables.
I think they are crucial and changed the
the environment. Even worse.
Cool. So let's take a look about the
problem. Let's see if they are, like,
connected to one another.
Oh, so we definitely can see that the
volume the PVC not found. Mhmm. So that's
been a problem with the PVC.
Let's try to do the. Right?
Yeah. Let's take rollback.
We don't have permission to do it because
it's your cluster, David.
It's also a get up cluster, so the
rollback wouldn't actually work. It would be overwritten
a few minutes later. However, the first
you've discovered
essentially the second problem. There is something that's
more
current with this deployment that you yes. We
will have to fix this too.
So Let's You mentioned the rates at the
start. Somebody said scheduling. Right?
Mhmm.
Let's look at the bugs guy.
The bugs themselves. Yeah.
Let's look at them.
Sending.
Other than the previous name?
Not scheduled. Not ready.
Yeah. Let's go back. We have information in
here, by the way, like, on the first
scheduling of the event. It would be much
easier to see it from here.
I think that
one note is not available.
No. Preemption.
Let's check the pods list first. Let's try
to check on the resources mode to see
that there's
node that is not ready and scheduling.
Maybe
let's try to unclog on it. It's something
called done. Mhmm. So you unclog on. Yeah.
I don't think we will have it. Maybe
let's go to the terminal and try to
fix it from the terminal. And you add
yourself? Can I try As a
Yeah? As a user?
Try
to add my my
personal name.
Do you want you to I I will
do that. Yeah. Okay. So we're doing, like,
a switch Yeah. Just because of security permissions
and because David created the cluster and the
account, basically.
And then we need to give the the
like, to add another team member
to the Komodor account. So, David, if you
can invite
Neil, it can be great. Yes. Yeah. Let's
go. Let's go to the notes.
Let's take the action and phone on call
Gong.
And
also, let's put the wall in between.
Everything at the same time. That's good.
Cool. So now, nearly, like, rolling back the
service.
No. Maybe the first deploy was not in
Komodor.
That's why.
I didn't say that it's probably.
I think it says that I'm in five.
Yeah.
No more of this will be found for
the comments.
We can also take the changes from the
GitHub and Oh, we can also take the
changes from Komodor. Right? And then from GitHub.
Yeah. From GitHub. I think the service was
deleted and then reinitiated.
Right? Like, it's generation one. It basically means
that, like, David played with the service apparently,
then he deleted the deployment, then he recreated
the deployment. With the failed configuration. Yeah. With
the failed configuration.
And that is the reason that the camera
can fall back because for us,
it's a new kind of services. They in
that it has a different unique ID,
and this is the first generation of the
new Google
deployment.
So we need to roll out
this
workload.
Yeah. Is the notes okay now? Let's just
check it. Yeah. They are okay. Do you,
like, check it on your screen? Or No.
No. I'm asking. I I can also check
it. No. It's still not ready. And I
know it's still not ready. Why is that?
Container WiFi network
is not ready.
It
looks like more like
a three s issue, I mean.
Yeah. We we need the network plug in
to be ready. Can we check
maybe on the services what is what's configured
as the network plug in?
Maybe let's try to take a look in
the YAML.
The network unavailable?
Okay. So what's the
the reason?
CNI is not initialized.
It's k three s. Right?
No. These are bare metal cube admin clusters.
Bare metal?
Oh, helpful here.
Maybe maybe
those are the things.
Yeah. This is a 48 core 64 gig
of RAM bare metal machine.
Okay. Okay.
So you can have some fun with it.
Right? Mhmm. Okay.
So let's recap where we are right now.
Using Komodor, we explored the broken service. So
we identified two bugs. One is that my
awesome update and get, which you were able
to visualize and see right away,
potentially broke the PVC claim name, which we're
gonna come back to, I would assume. I
also highlighted
that the
cluster couldn't schedule our pod, and you went
through the node dashboard and identified that the
node was cordoned, and you're able to uncoordinate
directly from Komodor,
moving us past the scheduling problem. However,
we now have the node being not ready
because of a potential issue with the CNI
networking
plugin.
Mhmm. Yeah.
Yeah. Like, we can see that there are,
like
I know, like,
four different plugins that are installed, CSI plugins
that are installed.
So CNI. We are looking for CNI, not
CSI. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Maybe
Let's try this quite maybe the node
guy. To what? Sorry. Describe node.
Oh, it looks like we have the same
operator installed
Yeah.
In in this cluster.
Yeah. It might be with the operator.
Yeah. There is no Maybe the CRDs of.
And there is the operator.
Maybe the helm. Yeah. The helm saying there
is, like, using helm.
Oh, there's a fail.
Deploy in here.
Fail deploy.
Yeah. Yeah. So we can see it's failed.
There is an agent through. Agent not ready.
Thank you
as well. Minimum replica unavailable.
Yeah.
But
it's just the it's just the operator itself.
On the deploy.
Let's take a look.
Deployment version one, Selium.
There is a spec of,
like, label, match label, IO Selium operator.
So let's see what Maybe it's it's the
port template that is on unmatched the deployment.
Do think, like, the relevant part in here?
Maybe.
Oh, it's it's funny. It's running and ready,
but it's
like, the node is not ready.
It's always fun watching people fix a broken
cluster.
Right.
Maybe, like have a look at the dashboard.
Oh, like, in the dashboard, we can see,
like, the.
Like, we can see quite a lot on
this.
Like, what annotation does this have? Oh, the
cluster. Yeah.
No. In the cluster. Yeah.
Just found it.
Exactly.
Maybe
let's check if there is
there is the setting cluster wall and cluster
wall binding in the cluster.
Do do you mean, like, those? Like, resources
which are not exist? Mhmm. I I think
we need to create something.
I'm not sure. Maybe let's check the logs
of the bot, which is running. No. I
think it's, like, on the annotation. Right? Like,
it doesn't find annotation on the node. And
this one doesn't install it on the node,
I think. It's running on the node.
So this may be a little bit harder
to debug because I think I found a
bug in Komodor, but try comparing the values
from the release three to release two.
Okay. Obsidian.
Yeah. Revolve it.
Okay.
So there are changes, but they don't actually
show up here. Yeah.
Maybe metadata changes?
We have only the three version. We don't
have the second one.
No. We do have it. We do?
Of the upper?
Ah, in the hand.
That's only show changes?
It doesn't show anything.
No. I do two and then comparing revision
two.
It's two
compared
with revision three.
No.
Yeah. I don't know why it's not showing
the change.
For me, it showed the changes. Wait. Then
manifests.
Then compare with version two. And here when
you do all the, it does show Here
is the changes. You deleted the service account
and all of those. The old back guy.
All the callback. I will do all the.
No. Yeah.
Maybe to do the role if we don't
have permission to. I
just performed the role back, but
try to quit.
Alright. Maybe it's a permission thing. Yeah. I
think the watcher doesn't have a permission maybe
for that. Mhmm. Yeah. It's possible. Yeah. Let's
see if also here we don't have any
permissions.
Secret faults.
Let's
do also we'll get to the We can't.
We can't? We can't program for one agent.
We need the the web access to the
to the cluster. Right? Yeah. So we will
use it.
So do all the to our agent, and
then we'll do to to the same Okay.
So I will show my screen. I will
stop sharing.
Yeah. So we found out that we're missing
permission
inside Komodor,
and it was installed without the possibility of,
like, doing a rollback.
Okay.
This is What costly do ah, okay.
Okay. Just a sec.
I'm all good.
Money.
4.
That's
it?
$2.02.
2 I try to do all the things.
Ah, okay. Can you okay. Yeah. That's that's
it.
Really? Okay.
Okay.
Now let's go back and check. It's gonna
be spreading now.
Yay. Is. Woo hoo. Yeah. He's right. Okay.
Okay.
And now let's check out our So before
we continue Mhmm. The
upgrades to Komodor, I did end Komodor because
it turned on dashboard.
But I see that it moved to secret
access, which is probably why the values didn't
show.
Yeah.
That's the reason. Okay. I just wanted to
make sure I understood what happened there. Okay.
Cool.
So
now the node is ready. Let's go back
to services.
And the only thing remaining is to bowl
of the version that we know for the.
Okay. So we have a working node and
you fixed the Celeb deploy. Nice work.
What we can Yeah. Now we need to
roll it back. So what we can we
we can't roll it back because what we
said So we need to edit, like, let's
edit it. Yeah. I think that I need
to show him screen because I Remember, this
is a GitOps pipeline, so you may want
me just to push a fix if you
could tell me what you want that fix
to be.
So get reversed? Yeah. Let's just get up
to the link if we wanna do it.
I don't know how to fix it. I
mean, I I just put awesome updates.
You don't need to tell me how to
fix it.
So please, I heard
your bad call.
Yeah.
So
Yeah. Let's let's
just recheck out to the, like, revision.
If nothing has changed in between, then that's
probably the easiest solution. We check out with
the rep before the change.
Are you doing the prep,
I have pushed an update
to get
I'm
Yes. I'm showing. I'm showing.
Do you have, like, a pipeline that know
how to like, is it automatically deployed? Yes.
Flux CD is running in the cluster. It
will detect this change, and it will push
it out. Speed up the process, and I
will just allow just so it's a bit
quicker.
Yeah.
So what we can see is that
we knew there was, the p p the
PVC change, and we got some one variable,
which can be missing and what they've been
changed.
Yeah. Once
It's only the PVC or maybe Maybe we
still need those. Yeah. So let's maybe
start from there.
Let's wait for the rollout to happen. Yeah.
We should see it in Komodor once the
rollout will happen. Let me update
here. We can take a look on the
Rawkode spots to see if it's pending still.
Yeah.
Yeah. But it's the previous one. Yeah. There
wasn't any good one since
So, honestly. So we are looking for a
new one. What?
So I did push the update. However, our
get out pipeline is broken due to the
fourth break in the cluster. So good luck.
So there's another break? Maybe I'll go. Right?
Like,
Yeah.
Let's let's check Argo. Is there Argo?
Flux. Sorry. It's Flux.
Source control notifications.
All of them look healthy.
What are you checking on? Sorry. The Outlook.
Alright. It's Slack. Yeah.
But maybe it's misconfigured
or something like that. Seems like the fax
is working fine. Let's check maybe the logs
of one of the workload. The controller or
some other service? The source controller, like, the
log message looks good.
The source controller.
The Maybe they didn't update by
source controller?
Or
I think there is still problem with the
ceiling.
Like, one of the ports are unhealthy.
And the source control logs The ceiling operator
is pending.
And schedule
because it didn't match for the.
If you go to the workload pods on
the white. Right?
Pods. Workload pods.
Click on the The operator is okay. It's
just because
we needed to roll back. I set the
replicas to one because we were single node
cluster, so you can ignore that pending pod.
No. Take the the the first pod.
Oh, you sound like it's just about fine.
It's not there, if anything? No. No. It's
like you said, like, in the logs of
the source control. Yeah. Yeah. It was there.
It was. There's, like, message for
Let me go back. And then garbage collected
one artifact. Why did the garbage collected it?
And then a lot of changes.
But why did the garbage collected one artifact?
Maybe it's related to that.
I don't know if that's. Store.
No changes in the.
Like, this is the change. This is what
you mean. Right? Yeah. And then, like, one
afterwards,
Type
in.
Yeah. This is the commit, like, David pushed.
Yeah. But what does it find?
Let's see if we got any warnings in
here. Or
You can do, like, maybe, like I don't
know.
So what happened is with one point, it
define it it find out that there there
was a change. Mhmm.
But for some reason,
the garbage collected it.
Maybe I need to change something in the
box.
Yeah.
Let's check the configuration. Maybe it's something about
this configuration thing.
Yeah. There is By the way, in the
customized controller, it always failed. The plug, the
name is changed from plug system to.
And what is the name in the log?
It's all that. Right? Yeah. Yeah.
So your rollback for Cilium actually fixed this
problem, but there's a ten minute sync time
on the customization.
So I've just encouraged it to run again.
So So
we don't need to do anything?
As long as this customization runs?
No. It's still failing. It says the network
and cluster is not working.
Yeah. I don't know if your rollback for
Cilium fixed the problem.
I think the rollback of Cilium didn't No.
Like, there if you look at the logs
of the customer's controller, there are really bad
logs there.
And it says that it failed on a
HTTP and
fairly common web.
Yeah. Let me just show that everyone can
see. Yeah. Reconciliation failed after a second.
That's the CMPG
webhook service.
Who is it?
Name.
The CMPG thing is
I think the network is still there.
What is this service?
The CMPG?
Yeah. There is, like, one thing here.
I'm looking at the logs of the CMPG.
Is it the pod? It's a there is
a pod,
but, like, the latest message is, like, periodic
PLS
certificate maintenance,
which I don't really know.
And
that's pretty much it around this service.
What was there in Volley in It doesn't,
like, succeed, like,
with the relevant service, basically.
Yes. So let me give you context on
that silly and break. Right? Because you've done
a rollback, but you didn't really identify what
the problem was and what changed. And Mhmm.
I don't want this to debug something
that
you can't have visibility into right now because
of that secret value thing. So in the
cell and health chart, what I did was
disable the agent, which is definitely rolled back
because we can see the agent is now
deployed next to the operator. However, I also
disabled
the eBPF Kube proxy replacement, and you may
notice there's no Kube proxy in this cluster.
So at the interest of not debugging something
that we're not entirely sure if it's been
fixed or not, I'm going to redeploy Selium
right now and assume the rollback
hopefully fixed it properly. And if we still
have an issue,
then I'm debugging with you because I'm not
really sure what the problem will be after
that. So let's let's see. Know. Maybe it's
worse.
I see see problem with with
the old. It's
It's not that.
I think So my my update for Cilium
has triggered
a redeploy of Cilium. So the contract might
definitely change. So we
may be moving in
to better situation.
Yeah. Let me delete the latest serial operator.
Oh, who can delete things?
Mhmm. Delete the serial operator.
Oh,
okay. Oh, cool.
No. By the previous one? Yeah. The previous.
But that one maybe.
Because the
operator
Wait a sec. Yeah. The the one that
is pending. No. Not the one that is
pending. It's the other one. Okay. What will
happen?
Yeah. So I'll go to the same operator
to the parts. Are you sure? Yeah.
I'm going to delete the old serial operator
port.
Oh, that's a bold move. I like it.
Yeah. Yeah. We're not playing around here. You
know?
So now the the new version is running
and
It should. Give one sec.
Or we won't have anyone there running. Right?
It's it seemed like it's failed schedule. Hey.
That worked.
Beautiful?
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, we have no doubts about that.
Seems like the the the new part of
the senior doesn't I like I
think that's okay because we have, like, two
replica. But now, like, it's a new one
that is running. Right?
So now what we should I can scale
it to one.
It's nice to try and just keep on
working. Let's get a new one. Issues,
you know. I'm
scaling the the same one for it to
one. No. Think that's the Symbol. No. I
think now it's okay. Now let hopefully, create
the the logs of the flex thingy there.
The customized
one? I think. Right? Let's see. Source. I
think the cus Oh, the group, I was
just thinking. Ah, it is? Yeah. You see?
If it's the final wall of yeah. Let's
see it.
When in doubt, delete still your operators.
Access everything.
Oh, now it's healthy. Woo.
Take look on the bots. Yeah. Yeah. Seems
like And I will do, like, a s
s a. Yeah. Know this one. Forward. That's
the default for. Okay.
Let me share my screen, and I'll test
the website for you. Alright?
Yeah.
And we understand, like,
all you get is, like, Drupal working. That's,
like, the best that's,
like, the best scenario.
The new one, Drupal Drupal is running. We
have a problem with our database configuration, but
maybe we don't need it. So in the
interest of testing, we can go port forward.
Why not doing port forward for the
Yeah. Why not? Yeah.
Komodor also have, like, like, another feature.
Okay. So it's
almost working. Let's see if we can actually
open up the browser.
Don't be too happy.
You have five to seven? No. He's going
to try to use the the database.
So this shouldn't actually be needed, but the
edit script is unable to run
for the same reason that this command will
fail.
Oh, no.
Our Drupal instance is unable to communicate with
the Postgres database.
Back over to you, and this is the
last break.
Because maybe the environment for that. Right? Like
the It's gonna time out. It cannot post
Drupal cannot speak to Postgres.
There we go.
Memory failure in DNS resolution.
Yeah. DNS resolution. Back to you. Last break.
What is the problem right now? So there
we go. So it cannot resolve the database.
And
okay. So let's check the events.
Of the pod?
Of everything.
Let's check.
Election
network policy?
Maybe.
We did a lot of network policy changes.
Indeed. Why?
Why did we deploy?
We're in
Komodor events.
We can see network policy
changes.
And the last network policy change
was
a lot of scraping. A lot of. So
we saw that there are a lot of
network policy changes.
And it's looked like someone changed,
like, the unpacking policy. Yeah. There is a
policy that's prevent us from executing
the request
Yeah. Out in the cluster. There is a
policy type of ingress.
So let's try to take on action and
details.
I mean, what I love about Komodor here,
right, is that the fed log is a
gold mine of information. And you can see
this network policy was created in the last
twenty four hours. It's obviously well intended,
but, you know, mistakes are easy to make
in Kubernetes.
Very
Done.
Alright. If you can stop sharing your screen,
I will give the application another spin. I
think we should be sitting pretty now. Because
I still have my portfolio running.
If
we remove the install script.
Yeah. We're already loading the views.
And if we make sure
Okay. Completed sixteen seconds ago. The database is
now running.
Oh, it shouldn't have to do this, but
we run through it anyway.
That's it.
Well
done. You fixed all of the breaks in
the cluster,
and Drupal is now working as intended. Cheers.
So, you know, a small recap, and then
I'll let you just get back about your
day. Right? But that's that's a whole lot
of fun for me. Right?
I actually found it really difficult
to break
the developer, the consumer API of Kubernetes in
a way that Komodor couldn't
show right up front what the problem was.
With the get integration, the depths, the helm
charts, the node information,
even revealing all the labels and annotations,
Everything was just there in front of me.
And I think that's just a superpower for
people that have to operate Kubernetes. So I
will thank you all for your work. A
bit harder to break, but I hope you
enjoyed each of the breaks that were presented
to you. And then, yeah, any final remarks
from anyone?
No. It was super fun.
I'm very fond of the movie.